with just seven days to go until
election day
democrats their allies the media mob are
doing
everything they can possibly do to
demoralize voters
especially the supporters of the
president and despite major progress in
our fight against covert 19 including
advancements
that are huge in therapeutics multiple
final human stage trials for a vaccine
courtesy of president trump's operation
warp speed
a rebounding economy we're expecting
massive
third quarter gdp numbers this week on
thursday
despite all of the good news there is
now a constant coronavirus hysteria
24 7 on every other news network they
want you to believe
there's no hope under president trump in
fact
according to the media research center
92 percent of all network news coverage
of the president has been negative
that's 92 percent
and right on cue joe biden predicting
the dark winter
unless you elect him apparently nobody's
told them about the therapeutics
and the vaccines that we're very close
to getting
that's right the cognitively struggling
weak frail 77 year old
who often doesn't even remember who he's
running against
is somehow going to instantly rescue
america from covert 19.
today biden accidentally even called his
running mates
husband kamala kamala's wife
he said it this seems to happen every
time joe misses his nap
and yesterday he struggled mightily to
answer a simple
unscripted question take a look
here's the deal here's the deal one of
the things that
that is important is that
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh barrett
that's the guy that's going to save the
world from everything now his stated
plans on covet for example already been
completed
and completely implemented already done
by president trump
maybe he missed it he he was napping the
whole time
hiding in his basement joe's barely able
to leave that bunker for more than one
day at a time in fact
as of now there are no public events
scheduled for joe tomorrow
less than one week away from the
election joe still
constantly taking days off the media mob
wants you to think joe has it
in the bag they're constantly touting
polls they're saying joe is in the lead
in the lead no chance for trump but keep
in mind
these are the same polls that got it
wrong in 2016.
and coming up on this program we will
talk to two pollsters
that actually got it right in 2016.
we'll get their take on the state of the
race one
is robert cahally from the trafalgar
group
who is now showing the president with a
lead in michigan
also showing a lead for the president in
pennsylvania
and nearly a three-point lead in the
state of north carolina
very important state meanwhile he's
showing a one-point lead
for biden and wisconsin if president
trump wins any combination of those
states
he will be well on his way to
re-election but as you can see
the margins are like 2016 razor thin
anything can happen my advice to all of
you
you're the ultimate jury is assume that
your vote will be the deciding vote
if everyone wants to stop the radical
biden harris
bolshevik bernie aoc anti-fossil fuel
higher taxes
open border amnesty packing the court
agenda
you're going to need to vote and
according to the hill democrats are now
underperforming in early voting in three
critical swing
states that would be florida iowa nevada
and keep in mind the enthusiasm gap is
enormous
joe biden is lucky to have a dozen
people at an event even with jon bon
jovi
and meanwhile everywhere the president
goes he's greeted
by massive historic unprecedented
crowds supporters waiting in line
hours and hours and hours even sleeping
overnight to hear the president speak
his rallies are held at huge and massive
venues filled with tens of thousands of
people
so what does it mean for the upcoming
election